food shortages crisis at the border even
the risk of rioting across the UK the
government has released its assessment
of what could happen if the UK leaves
the EU without a deal and it makes for
startling reading the six pages of
operation yellowhammer warned that in
the worst case scenario there could be
long delays at channel crossings
significant electricity price rises and
impacts on medicine and food supplies
well the document says certain types of
fresh food supply will decrease with a
risk that panic buying will cause or
exacerbate food supply disruption on
medicines it warns that supplies will be
vulnerable to severe delays it will also
not be practical to stockpile products
to cover expected delays of up to six
months if they expected disruption at
channel ports it says there will be
significant queues in Kent with delays
of one and a half to two and a half days
before being able to cross the border on
fuel supplies the documents say border
delays could affect fuel distribution
customer behavior could lead to local
shortages in other parts of the country
and it warns that violence could break
out protests and counter protests will
take place across the UK and may absorb
significant amounts of police resource
there may also be a rise in public
disorder and communities tensions let's
go straight then to Westminster and our
deputy political editor Sam Coates
reaction has been ferocious Sam how bad
is it
nineteen bullet points each one eye
watering the possible consequences of a
No Deal brexit government tonight
playing down the warnings suggesting
that they were prepared for Theresa
Mae's government using old assumptions
and that they are working hard to make
sure that none of these things become
the truth yet with their warnings here
tonight of what might happen on October
the 31st many of them make stark reading
areas like Medicine
the document is uncompromising it says
while some products will be soft can be
stockpiled
others have short shelf lives and it's
not practical to stockpile products to
cover expected delays of six months
you mentioned riots it talks about
public disorder food prices and
electricity prices set to rise I think
there's going to be a lot of anger about
the contents of this document and some
cross to about the way in which these
warnings are worded no doubt some trying
to blast them as project fear and
attempt perhaps by officials to convince
the incoming Boris Johnson government
out of doing an Odile brexit this
document is date is August the second
just weeks after the new prime minister
took took office nevertheless the anger
from those opposed to an Odile brexit
and in comprehend uncomprehending about
Britain might be to be preparing to take
the kind of risks contained in this
document has been Swift let's hear from
Phillip Lee who until last week but who
last week became a Liberal Democrat MP
previously a conservative it is shocking
I mean really did people in 2016 vote to
have problems accessing clean water did
they vote to have problems accessing
necessary emergency medicines did they
vote to have problems with access to
fresh food of course they didn't
what is the political fallout likely to
be and does the Prime Minister still
believe that a clean break brexit is
worth pursuing
so Boris Johnson will face questions not
of course in the Parliament because
that's parade MPs sent away on Monday
night for five weeks nevertheless he
will be called upon in the coming days
to reassure the public why these are a
risks that might just might have to be
worth taking it's been interesting
talking to conservative MPs some of them
have been talking to him about a No Deal
brexit in recent days just last week a
couple of Tory MPs told me he was saying
that was each individual measure for a
No Deal brexit might in itself be able
to be overcome
that in totality this does present a
massive challenge in 2001 Tony Blair
delayed a general election because of
delays at refineries meaning fuel
shortages and queues at petrol pumps
that by the way is understood to be
what's behind the blacked out or
censored section from tonight's document
that alone was enough to cause massive
disruption to brock politics as well as
economics and business here is 19
different things that could cause
enormous challenges it's a hell of a
gamble the government is going to have
to provide some reassurance in the days
to come